PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Cat-Out has decided
to set up their packaging
subscriber on Cloud Functions.
Stay tuned to find out how.
So far in the series, we
learned about Cloud Pub/Sub
and how it works using Cat-Out's
Asynchronous Order Processing
Service.
We saw how Pub/Sub helps
manage the interactions
between the order, packaging,
shipping, and notification
services.
In the sixth episode, we
learned that Cloud Pub/Sub
supports both push and
pull message delivery.
Quick recap.
You use pull if you don't have
public HTTPS endpoints, which
means your service is private
or firewalls are involved.
Pull is also more efficient
and minimizes latency.
So if events are generated
at a really high rate,
like hundreds or thousands
of events per second,
then pull is the way to go.
Also, push delivery requires the
client endpoint is a publicly
accessible HTTPS server.
Luckily, this is easy to
set up with Cloud Functions.
Today, let's dive
a bit deeper into
push subscribers for Cat-Out.
Setting up Pub/Sub
to send messages
to a client using push
delivery is extremely easy.
It requires no special
client libraries, just
a standard HTTPS
endpoint routable
by DNS and a web server to
respond to these requests.
It's also a lightweight
way of programming,
particularly with
web server frameworks
such as Cloud Functions,
Cloud Run, and App Engine.
You simply write the server
code and let the framework
take care of the communication.
Of course, you can choose
to host this application
on a virtual machine
anywhere you like.
It's usually more effort,
but if that's something
you need to do.
But our friends at
Cat-Out are all in
for the lightweight programming.
So they decided to use Cloud
Functions for the packaging
subscriber that
receives messages
from the order service.
That Pub/Sub push request coming
to the packaging subscriber
would be HTTPS post.
That looks like this, where the
data field is base64 encoded,
and the subscription is defined.
Once processed, the
packaging subscriber
sends a success response, like
200, 201, 202, 204, and 102
are interpreted as
message acknowledgments
by the Cloud Pub/Sub system.
Pub/Sub does not send a
negative acknowledgment.
So if the packaging webhook
does not return a success code
within the default
acknowledgment deadline,
then Pub/Sub retries
delivery until the message
expires after the subscription's
message retention period.
Oh, and the cool part,
the rate of push delivery
is automatically adjusted
to maximize delivery rate
while not overwhelming
the push endpoint.
This is accomplished using
a slow-start algorithm.
Let's see how this works.
The system starts by sending
a single message at a time.
With each successful delivery,
the number of messages sent
is doubled.
And the rate continues to
double until there is a delivery
failure or the system reaches
a quota or resource limits.
For each delivery
failure, the number
of concurrent requests
to the endpoint
halves until a minimum of
one request is reached.
So this algorithm
assumes that there
are enough published
messages in the queue
to sustain this throughput.
Ultimately, the
push delivery rate
is constrained by the rate at
which messages are published.
We understand the basics of
how a message is structured
and the slow-start
algorithm works.
But we did not discuss the most
important piece of the puzzle--
how does Cat-Out authenticate
and authorize Pub/Sub
to make a call to the
subscriber endpoint?
There are a few options.
Let's see.
They could just set up
the packaging subscriber
with no authentication, which
is not a really good option
for a private service.
So the real first option
for authentication
is that the publisher sends
a custom authorization
token as a part of the message.
The subscriber then
authenticates that token.
The second
authentication option is
to configure the
push subscription
to include a signed
OpenID Connect
token for a GCP service account
in the authorization header.
And the push endpoint
can use this token
to validate that the request is
issued on behalf of the service
account associated
with the subscription
and make an
authorization decision.
We know that Cat-Out
has chosen to set up
Cloud Function as the
packaging subscriber.
With Cloud Function,
the authentication
and authorization
is even easier,
because it uses the
standard IAM permissions.
Your code just
handles the message
and attributes while Function
manages the request, parsing,
and responding to Pub/Sub
To find out how simple
it is, let's set this up
and see for ourselves.
So let's create a Pub/Sub
topic and then create a Cloud
Function in the same
project by clicking
on the Trigger Cloud Function
button right from the topic
itself.
It autopopulates the trigger
as Cloud Pub/Sub, the topic,
and the function name.
Once the function is
created, we go to our topic
and publish a message.
Now it is time to check
if the message was
received by our Cloud
Function subscriber.
We navigate to Logs,
filter on Cloud Function,
and see that our
message is received.
Now, you may ask, what if
Cat-Out's packaging subscriber
has to go in maintenance
mode for some time?
In temporary
situations like that,
it is recommended to change
the subscription to pull.
And when the service is
ready to take requests,
just set the URL to a
valid endpoint again.
If Cat-Out decides to change
the packaging subscriber
to a different
service altogether,
then they would have to
permanently stop delivery
to the old endpoint.
In such cases, it is
recommended to just delete
the subscription,
create a new one,
and add the new
subscriber to it.
All right.
So today we learned that push
subscriber is a simple HTTPS
endpoint.
We learned the different
authentication authorization
mechanisms and saw how
easy it is to set up a push
subscriber on Cloud Functions.
Stay tuned for the
next episode, where
we will help Cat-Out
set up a subscriber
endpoint on Cloud Run.
Until then, give us
a like, subscribe,
and let us know what you want
to learn about Cloud Pub/Sub.